[beatboxing]
Love her, but there's
this bangin' black chick
on the swim team
that I've been bang--
Love her, but there's--
Love her, but there--
[laughter]
You know, you got to have
the perfect outfit
for these sort of things.
You gots to look fancy.
- Oh!
- You gotta be fresh.
- Sounded good.
- ♪ You gotta, you gotta ♪
(both)
♪ You gotta be fresh ♪
(Blake)
What happened with--
they lost, right?
Get in there.
(Adam)
They marched back in the fourth
and almost--
You're a little bitch.
You're probably not even
gonna give gum.
Gum.
[chuckles]
You're not probably
giving friggin'--
You're probably not even
gonna give--
(man)
Reset.
But that's what the weed's for,
right?
That's what we chief
that Connie for, huh?
That's why we put the spliff
to the lips, huh?
That's why we chief that kief,
huh?
Okay, that's why I be...
[inhales and exhales]
I'm finally home.
- Oh, shit.
[laughter]